growing up this was one of my favorite
meals to eat we didn't have it often
since they're very time consuming but it
is a labor of love that is very worth it
the most tedious part is deboning the
chicken you want to crack the bones to
loosen it and then I like to use both my
kitchen shears and the paring knife and
so you want to cut off the meat as close
to the bone as you can this takes some
practice it usually takes me about three
minutes per Wing but take your time and
you'll get the hang of it for the
filling I'm using minced pork for
methylene noodles rehydrated whatever
mushrooms and make sure to remove all of
that excess moisture for each ingredient
that you add carrots salt and pepper soy
sauce dark soy sauce oyster sauce fish
sauce and an egg
there are probably going to be some
holes as you fill the wings but this is
fine you can use toothpicks to close it
and also add more to close the top then
I'm lathering with oil and seasoning
with salt and I'm baking this on a rack
at 400 for 40 minutes turning halfway
and basting with a soy sauce fish sauce
and brown sugar glaze these also taste
even better grilled and I'm pairing this
with sweet chili sauce